♪ ♪
>> Jesse: THE LIBERAL MEDIA
SCORN FOR THE PRESIDENT IS ON
FULL DISPLAY, COMPETING WITH
HOSTILE REPORTERS DURING THE
PRESS BRIEFINGS, FOR GOOD
REASON.
CHECK OUT THIS RIDICULOUS GOT
YOU A QUESTION.
>> WOULD AN AMERICAN PRESIDENT
LOSING MORE AMERICANS IN SIX
WEEKS OVER THE INTEGRITY OF THE
VIETNAM WAR, DOES HE DESERVE TO
BE REELECTED?
>> WE HAVE LOST A LOT OF PEOPLE,
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT ORIGINAL
PROJECTIONS WERE, 2.2 MILLION,
WE ARE PROBABLY HEADING TO
60,000, 70,000, ONE PERSON IS
FAR TOO MANY FOR THIS.
>> Jesse: PLUS "THE VIEW HAS A
NEW TARGET, DR. DEBORAH BROOKS,
DEFENDING THE EXPERT FORWARD
DEFENDING TRUMP.
>> AT THIS POINT SHE IS LESS OF
A DOCTOR AND MORE LIKE AN
ELDERLY CARE NURSE TO THIS GUY.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT DR. BIRX IS
PART OF THE PROBLEM?
>> I DO, I DO THINK SHE IS PART
OF THE PROBLEM.
IT GIVES ME NO PLEASURE TO SAY
THAT.
YOU CAN’T BE COMPLICIT IN A TIME
LIKE THIS, DR. BIRX.
SO I THINK SHE HAS BECOME PART
OF THE PROBLEM.
>> Jesse: WOW.
WELL, I DON’T THINK -- I’M NOT
EVEN GOING TO ADDRESS THE
DOMESTIC "THE VIEW" LADIES.
I HAVE SEEN MY FAIR NUMBER OF
GOTCHA QUESTIONS, SHE PLAYED IT
PRETTY WELL WITH THE PRESIDENT.
I JUST DON’T KNOW IF I COULD
EVER BRING MYSELF TO ASK A
GOTCHA QUESTION LIKE THAT TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THAT BEFORE?
>> Dana: HAVE I EVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THAT BEFORE?
I WORKED THROUGH A PRESIDENT
DURING A TIME OF WAR, TORTURERS,
MEMOS, YEAH.
I’VE SEEN IT BEFORE.
AND A LITTLE BIT OF THAT, YOU
GET INTO A CHANCE WHERE YOU HAVE
THE CAMERAS ON, AND SHE IS A
REPORTER THAT HAS WRITTEN SOME
PRETTY GREAT THINGS.
SHE HAS BROKEN A LOT OF STORIES.
AND SHE IS WRITING A BOOK ABOUT
THE 2020 ELECTION, SO THE
QUESTION ABOUT DOES A PRESIDENT
LIKE YOU DESERVED TO BE
REELECTED WAS GEARED TOWARDS
WHERE SHE IS THINKING AND WHERE
SHE IS SPENDING HER TIME.
BUT REMEMBER, THE PRESIDENT
ANSWERED IT SO WELL.
SO SOMETIMES IT DOESN’T MATTER
IF THE QUESTION IS HOSTILE, IF
YOU HIT A HOME RUN, THEN WHO
CARES?
IT ACTUALLY MAKES YOU LOOK
BETTER.
AND I WILL SPEAK TO THE DOCTOR
BIRX THING FOR A SECOND, WAY TO
STAND UP FOR WOMEN, LADIES.
OKAY, JOY BEHAR, TRYING TO LOOK
LIKE DR. BIRX WITH THE SCARF.
IT’S A LOOK I CANNOT PULL OFF,
BUT I WOULD TRY AT SOME POINT.
BUT HERE IS A WOMAN WHO IS
HAVING A RESPONSIBILITY NOT TO
CODDLE ANYBODY.
SHE IS SUPPOSED TO TRY TO MANAGE
A PANDEMIC.
AND SHE IS DOING THAT WITH THE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
SO WHY DON’T I JUST LET HER DO
HER JOB FOR AS LONG AS SHE NEEDS
TO DO IT, AND TO DO IT TO THE
BEST OF HER ABILITY AND DO IT
PROFESSIONALLY.
WHICH IS WHAT SHE HAS BEEN DOING
DOING.
>> Jesse: SHE HAS BEEN DOING A
VERY GOOD JOB.
GREG, I’M GOING TO PLAY SOME
SOUND OF ANOTHER EXCHANGE,
AGAIN, JUST CRAZY, CRAZY
COMMENTARY FROM THE PRESS CORPS.
THE PRESIDENT AND DR. BIRX WERE
ASKED SOMETHING, YOU CAN REACT
TO ALL OF IT.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO APOLOGIZE?
>> GO AHEAD.
THAT’S WHY NOBODY KNOWS WHO YOU
ARE INCLUDING ME.
GO AHEAD.
YOU WANT TO GET YOUR FACTS
RIGHT.
>> WE HAVE FACTS.
>> WELL, YOUR FACTS ARE WRONG.
>> Jesse: HE ASKED THE
QUESTION AND SAID, WE ARE BEHIND
SOUTH KOREA, ACTUALLY, NO, WE
ARE AHEAD OF SOUTH KOREA.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT HAPPEN A
LOT.
>> Greg: THIS IS THE GOTCHA
QUESTION GAME SHOW.
I WANT TO TIE WHAT OLIVIA NEWSY
AND THE BIRX THING HAVE IN
COMMON.
HER QUESTION IS THE PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF MEDIA NARCISSISM, IT
IS GUARANTEEING ATTENTION BACK
TO THE PERSON ASKING THE
QUESTION PRAYED I’M SURE SHE GOT
DMed FROM ACOSTA AND THE BALD
GUY SAYING WOW, THAT WAS AMAZING
WHAT YOU DID TO HER.
BUT THE QUESTION IS ABSURD.
WHO DO YOU DESERVED TO BE
REELECTED?
WELL, THAT’S WHAT THE ELECTION
WILL DETERMINE, YOU.
AND YOU CAN PUT IT LIKE, LET’S
PUT IT THIS WAY, GIVEN THE
TORNADO HIT YOUR TOWN AND KILLED
30 PEOPLE, DO YOU DESERVE TO BE
DOGCATCHER?
THAT’S EXACTLY HOW STUPID HER
QUESTION WAS.
NOW WHEN YOU FOCUS ON BIRX, IT’S
CALLED THE CONTAMINATION EFFECT.
THE MEDIA LOVES TO JUST SOIL HER
REPUTATION, BECAUSE BY -- IF YOU
ARE HANGING AROUND SOMEBODY WE
HATE, TRUMP, THEN YOU ARE
CONTAMINATED.
THEY TRANSFER THEY HATE TO HER.
SO WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT
BIRX KNOWS?
RIGHT, ARE THEY CONTAMINATED BY
NOW KNOWING HER?
YOU SEE HOW THIS THING WORKS?
THEY SHOULD DO TRACE -- WHATEVER
THEY CALL IT, CONTACT TRACING ON
EVERYBODY’S FRIENDSHIPS.
SO LASTLY, WHY DO THEY HAVE
SOMETHING IN COMMON?
THE MEDIA IS HYPOCRITICALLY
EVIL.
WHEN THEY MOVE STOMACH INTERVIEW
UNSAVORY PEOPLE, THEY ARE
IMPARTING THEIR GOOD MORAL FIBER
ON THEM.
SO WHEN THEY QUESTION TRUMP,
THEY ARE ACTUALLY THE MORAL HIGH
GROUND, WHICH IS WHY SHE HAD HER
ABSURD QUESTION, BUT WHEN YOU
WILL, LIKE BIRX IS AMONG TRUMP,
THEN YOU ARE THE RECIPIENT OF
THE UNSAVORY NESTS OF TRUMP.
NOW YOU ARE NOW IMMORAL BY A
BEING AROUND HIM.
SO, YOU SEE THE TRICK.
TO THE MEDIA GETS TO DECIDE WHO
GETS TO IMPART MORAL VALUE, AND
IT IS ALWAYS THEM, BUT IT IS
NEVER YOU.
>> Jesse: THAT’S A GOOD POINT.
JUAN, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Juan: I THINK THE PRESS IS
SUPPOSED TO HOLD POWERFUL PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE AND ASK QUESTIONS.
NOW, I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
NEVER SHY, NEVER SHY ABOUT
SAYING, HEY, THAT’S A CRAZY
QUESTION, OR THAT IT IS AN
UNFAIR QUESTION, OR THAT IT IS A
FAKE NEWS QUESTION, BUT HE DID
NOT DO THAT.
TREATED IT SERIOUSLY, AND AS
DANA POINTED OUT, HE GAVE WHAT I
THINK WAS A PRETTY GOOD ANSWER
FROM HIS PERSPECTIVE.
HE SAID THE NUMBERS ARE LESS
THAN WHAT HAD BEEN PROJECTED,
AND THEN TRY TO TAKE CREDIT FOR
IT.
AND BY THE WAY, IT WAS NOT A
GOTCHA QUESTION, IT WAS A REAL
QUESTION.
I THINK THAT THEY ARE REAL
QUESTIONS TO COME LIKE TODAY
ABOUT BANKS AND EVEN SOME OF THE
BORROWERS UPSET ABOUT THE FDA
SCREW UP WITH THE COMPUTERS,
PEOPLE CANNOT GET THE LOANS.
PEOPLE ARE UPSET ABOUT THESE BIG
COMPANIES, SOME OF THESE AUTO
COMPANIES, THE L.A. LAKERS
GETTING LOANS IN THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES.
PEOPLE HAVE LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS
TO ASK.
AND I DON’T THINK IT IS
ILLEGITIMATE FOR THE PRESIDENT
TO ASK THEM.
WHEN THEY ARE GOTCHA QUESTIONS
LIKE WHO IS THE LEADER OF BLUES
PAKISTAN OR SOMETHING, DANA
WOULD KNOW ABOUT THAT KIND OF
SILLY QUESTION.
>> Jesse: DOES DANA KNOW?
>> Juan: BUT A LEGITIMATE
QUESTION --
>> Dana: I DO NOT KNOW THE
LEADER.
BEFORE GOTCHA.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, EMILY.
>> Emily: I THINK THAT THIS
UNDERSCORES THE HYPOCRISY,
BECAUSE RESPECTFULLY, JUAN, IF
HER QUESTION WAS TRULY DESIGNED
TO PROVOKE CONVERSATION, THEN
WHY WHEN SHE WAS CALLED OUT THAT
HER QUESTION WAS JUST DESIGNED
TO PROVOKE, SHE RESPONDED "SHUT
THE F UP."
AND FOR JOY BEHAR, THAT’S JUST
AN EXAMPLE OF SOMEONE WHO USES
THE MEDIA PLATFORM TO ATTACK
THOSE WHO ATTACK WOMEN, AND SHE
IS A HILLARY CHAMPION, SHE CALLS
HERSELF A FEMINIST.
AND YET, THIS OPPORTUNITY, SHE
CALLS DR. BIRX WAS A U.S. ARMY
COLONEL AND LITERALLY LEAD THE
HIV VACCINE GLOBAL MOVEMENT.
AND HAS RECEIVED TONS OF
COMMENDATION AWARDS UNDER
DEMOCRATIC ADMINISTRATIONS.
AND TO MANAGE $1.5 BILLION OF
BUDGET, LITERALLY LEAD AND JOY
BEHAR REDUCES HER TO AN ELDERLY
CARE NURSE.
I COULD COMPARE AND CONTRAST JOY